Allow me to introduce the rest of us.
We're the makers, the directors and the creators of this generation.
We don't have big award shows or huge budgets or fancy cameras,...
...but what we do have are our phones and duct tape and parking lots and guts...
...and we have ideas we need to share.
We know it's not the size of the production that matters; it's what you make.
We don't create because we have to,...
...we create because we love to,...
...and we've captured billions of moments from different angles...
...for different reasons, for millions of viewers,...
...but with one thing in common.
When we're told that we can't, we all have the same answer.
Watch me.
Thank you.